hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's einen ja fast schon ein
klassiker ein klassisches grundrezept
und zwar mache ich einen quark öl teig
und daraus mache ich dann einen
kirschkuchen wirklich einfachen dieter
marquardt ganz viele kirschen das ja
nach teure kirschen müssen was machen
die haben halt hier aus kilo also
momentan coach kiel und das hilton dass
die zuschauer das wissen ja fünf euro 90
oder man geht halt in den garten alten
kirschbaum hat und kann da ganz viele
kirchen ganz kostenlos und nutze info da
ich gerade vor paar wochen alleine
wollen normale türkei war dort kosten
kilo kirschen 30 cent
ich mache hier schon ganz gerne
was ich nicht mag wenn da ständig wer
immer drin sein also ich kann hier schon
immer ganz gut essen aus sobald ich ein
wunder in der kann ich sie nicht mehr
essen
ich glaub es nicht so ist das schicksal
tasks mit sehr vielen leuten ja nein
hawk beherrschen mein opa hat im axa
kirschen muss man einfach im dunkeln
essen ehrlich und mein mann immer gesagt
wenn wohl drin ist seit froh drüber dann
ist eine gute nachricht mit gift mein
papa auch wer ist dann auch das der
kennt ja nix naja egal ob wurm drin oder
nicht
bei uns haben jetzt keine drin ich habe
zu diesem quark öl teig und den leckeren
kuchen und zeigt euch mal ganz christi
zutaten für den quark öl teig brauche
ich 150 gramm magerquark 50 milliliter
geschmacksneutralen öl zum beispiel
sonnenblumenöl 1 150 milliliter milch
etwas meinl extrakt 75 g zucker 300
gramm mehl und ein päckchen backpulver
und für die füllung brauchen wir später
noch 500 gramm kirschen eine bio zitrone
und drei esslöffel zucker jetzt nämlich
zuerst einmal die flüssigen zutaten also
das zeug auch mit dazu den gebe ich
jetzt in eine große schüssel unterteilt
ist auch wirklich ganz ein
nach
das öl mit rein das ait und den mails
und weil ich wandel extrakt benutzer
kommt man den extrakt mit rein
es wird jetzt alles ganz kurz mit dem
schneebesen verfüllt
jetzt kommen auch die trockenen zutaten
rein erste zucker und mehl und
backpulver und das ganze verknetet jetzt
mit der küchenmaschine aber er könnte
jetzt natürlich auch die hände benutzen
und der teig muss jetzt ganz schnell
verknetet werden und ganz kurz
ansonsten wir dann nicht so schön locker
hatte nicht wie bei einem hefeteig lange
kneten sondern nur kurz bis ich alles
schon verbunden hat es geht am besten
mit etwas strom
der teig ist jetzt fertig stay sitzt
schön luftig und locker aber klebt auch
nicht denn das jetzt ganz kurz stehenden
wetscher mal die kirchen in steinen und
zwar nämlich dafür ist einfach ein
messer halt wir sie unbedingt im haus
kann ich bereits den teig nehmen und
habe jetzt hier eine silikon matte
bisschen mit mehl bestreut nicht
bestäubt besteuert und da kommt jetzt
der teig drauf geht natürlich auch ohne
silikon mathe aber so habe ich um eine
schöne saubere arbeitsfläche jetzt nehmt
ihr wieder ein bisschen mehr
und falls der teig jetzt zu klebrig ist
könnt ihr auch noch 19 bei mehl
dazugeben
aber da ist wirklich super so also
gehört auf jeden fall so und falls
einmal zum fest ist kann man einfach ein
bisschen milch dazugeben
jetzt holte eine große platte aus
jetzt könnte überall mit sondern palette
mal runter gehen um zu gucken ob es
klebt und weiß es wirklich klebt habe
ich da einen trick für euch und zwar
nehmt ihr euch eine torten retter oder
zum beispiel flaches tag gleich gut
festhalten und einmal stürzen
da
dann kriegt was nämlich auch ganz gut ab
jetzt nehme ich die kirchen da kommt
jetzt etwas zitrone update mit rein
den könnte man beispielsweise aber auch
in den teig mit dazu geben je nachdem wo
ist dann haben wollt
also sieht zwar aus wie eine limette
meister grün ist aber es ist wirklich
mit zitrone die schalt mich gern aber
limette wird aufgelassen und jetzt noch
den zucker mit rein und dann ganz kurz
beruhigen
und jetzt muss die tagblattes
zurechtgeschnitten werden und zwar
können die letzten normales nestern
lebenden teig schneider oder zum
beispiel das gesegnet und da legt ihr
euch jetzt am besten eine kirche zuerst
eick platte und zwar musste die
teigplatten später so zusammendrücken
können wie so eine rolle
deswegen müssen jetzt die streifen breit
genug sein das am besten ein bisschen
mehr als doppelt so breit und dann
zurechtschneiden
jetzt lege ich die kirschen einfach
aneinander
hier mal die äußeren stück geweckt und
dann werden jetzt die teigplatten
zusammengedrückt dass große rollen
entstehen
man kann die zeit bleibt natürlich auch
etwas breiter machen da hat muss einfach
mit ihm zusammen drücken
aber je bereitet ist umso weniger frucht
hat meyer drin so im verhältnis deswegen
habe ich jetzt etwas enger geschnitten
und es geht ja auch so ganz gut zusammen
hier sind wir diese teig rollen und
nehmen sie am besten mit einer palette
oder mit einem großen messer auf man
kommt auf einen backpapier und wenn sie
zu einer schnecke gerollt am besten mit
der naht nach unten
und falls ihr jetzt nicht so geübt sein
könnte das echt erstmal mit einem
hefeteig zum beispiel ausprobieren das
ein bisschen elastischer quark öl teig
ist ja nicht so elastisch dann kann man
eben nicht ziehen
aber wenn man ganz vorsichtig arbeitet
klappt es auch ganz gut
jetzt könnt ihr den so backen oder ihr
nehmt noch einen tortenring gibt den
außen rumpeln behälter auch eine runde
schöne form und so kann er auch gleich
in baku
so wie jetzt im backofen bei 190 grad
ober unterhitze etwa 25 minuten gebacken
die stadt suchen etwas farbe angenommen
hat der cash warren ist gebacken und ich
habe noch etwas abkühlen lassen könnte
den hochnehmen mit dem tortenring auf
eine platte zu fuß sondern können damit
im tortenring messers in torten rahmen
lösen
und jetzt kommt noch einen topping
obendrauf und zwar könnte jetzt entweder
einen guss machen oder ihr nehmt etwas
puderzucker oder so wie ich süßer schnee
das süße schnee bleibt dann nämlich
schön drauflegen und schmilzt dann eben
auch nicht auch wenn feuchtigkeit unter
ist
so etwas muss ein stück probieren ich
schneide jetzt mal was raus gesprungen
ist sehr warm essen oder man kann diesen
warm essen aber ich habe jetzt bisschen
abgelassen damit die kirschen innen drin
dass die ersten sich zu heißen und
zweitens damit der saft zechen bis level
i also nicht dass ich jetzt immer warm
mehr mag ob es ja immer leute die es
lahm
sauer
erst mal gern nebendran nähe zu locken
sprühsahne sieht natürlich besser aus
dem skalieren kann er
man kann es auch noch der spritzbrühe
spritzbeutel füllen und rau spritzen das
geht natürlich auch super
das krieg ich noch eine schöne kirche
dank bin ich mal gespannt ist glaub du
es sogar zeigt er schon den ersten mal
quartal habe ich einen gegessen ich weiß
ja lieber sind das war
ich habe schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht
okay also jetzt erstmal die seine
branche nicht probieren ich probier für
die kirche das will ich sagen hitze aufs
foto rothe wasser schön die kirche schon
lecker wenn die kirche schon länger an
der courage ausgefallen hier schon mit
ich sollte steht bei jeder gabel eine
kirsche mit granaten
ich glaub ich hab schon mal quark öl
teig gegessen
ja von meiner mama glaube nein das
wollten als frage mich bestimmt wieder
meine zuschauer aus der türkei wasser
des staates wahrnehmen können also was
ich mir gut vorstellen könnte weil es
gibt doch noch irgendwie keinen quark
außer frucht gewackelt haben wir doch
schon entdeckt eventuell könnte man es
auch mal mit dem joghurt probieren der
fettanteil hat aber das könne problemlos
drückte auch funktionieren schmeckt
natürlich ein bisschen anders aber es
könnte alles super mehr als 1
bekommen wir vom bovert heute sowieso
nicht falls ihr jetzt autos bekommen
habe auf diesen kuchen dann geht auch
sallys - trug der täter stets noch mal
für euch und ich wünsche ganz viel spaß
beim nachhaken süßlich schmecken ist
kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor ich weiß
aber wie vorher
jetzt stoppte den kuchen nicht reinmacht
doch auf dein t und dann genießen oder
nicht ist die sahne zusammenfällt ist
lieber schnell an erster stelle
ok macht's gut